お待たせいたしました
毎年恒例
けんこんしぃだん(？)
あっ
えっ？
あれやばい、日本語がわからん！！
ぶるるるるる
健康診断発表のコーナーでございます
[拍手]
はい、というわけで私、はじめしゃちょー、の！
僕だけじゃなくて周りも含め、なんですけどもー
僕の周りで一緒に働いている人たち全員で
毎年4月に人間ドッグに行っております。
なんせ、
健康が
一番大事ですからね？
まぁ何かあってからじゃ遅いということで
早期発見が何よりも大切ということで
健康診断じゃなくて、
私たち、人間ドッグを行っております。
一昨日検査したんですけどもー
もう3日前に飯食わなかったり
水飲まなかったり
こう、なんか、尿検査したり
こう、なんか……
ね。
ちょっと、あまりしゃべると下品になるんですけども
もう大なり小なりをいろいろかき集め
こう検査したわけなんですけどもー！
え〜〜結果発表していきたいと、思います。
なんか普通ね、まだこの年だと
「健康診断でいいやん」みたいなことを
言われやすいんですけどー
大学卒業してから毎年受けてるんですけどもー
「なんか早いね」ってめっちゃ言われるんですよ
「えっ？
えっ、24歳でもう人間ドッグ受けてんの？」
みたいな、感じで言われるんですけどー
健康診断じゃ分からない細かいことも！
人間ドッグだと分かるということで
もう念には念を入れて
僕を含め、畑のみんな、あと僕の後輩とか、みんな！
人間ドッグ受けさせていただいております。
みんなの情報は
ちょっと畑で出ると思うんですけどもー
ここは僕の情報を
みなさんにお伝えしようと、思います。
はい、じゃあ順番に発表していきましょう
まずは身体計測です
身長が今回、186.3
今まで186ちょっとなかったんスけど
なぜか伸びて186.3になっておりました
まだ！！！
成長中かもしれませんねぇえ！！！
贅沢な悩み！！
体重がですねー
70.1kgになってしまいました…
やばい。
2年前は65.6
そして去年が68、今年が70キロ
年々増えてってやがる(ドス)
ここはちょっとお医者さんに指摘されましたね
「やばいっスよ？」って
「今はこのペースなんですけど
年取るとガッと速くなるんで
どこかで食生活を見直したらいいよ」
っていうことを言われました。
野菜食べます。
で、標準体重がですね、いずれにせよ僕、
75キロとか76キロとかなんで
70キロでもまだ痩せてる方なんですよ
ただこのまま行くと76キロになっちゃいそうなんで
ちょっとどこかでこう、ストップしたいっていうか
抑えたいっていうところでございます
続いて肥満度！
えぇと、まだ -8.2%です
マイナスなのでまだセーフです
続いてBMIがえーと、20.2！
前回・前々回が19.7、19に比べて
20まで上がってしまいましたが まだ大丈夫です
体脂肪率が14%
ちょうどいい具合ですね一
基準値の一番下ぐらいなので
とてもバランスがいい状態になりました
お腹はちょっと膨れました
[舌打ち]
血圧！まぁ、問題無しです
視力。去年と変わらず0.7・0.6
裸眼です
眼圧も問題なかったです
ありがとうございます
聴力も問題なしです
尿検査も問題ないです
去年に続き今年も蛋白が多かったです
なぜでしょう。
えーと肝機能も特に問題なかったです
尿酸の値も問題なしです
ここが問題です
問題があるとしたら、ここだったかなぁー…
えぇっと脂質代謝ですね。
あの、なんかいわゆるデブってやつです
コレステロール値が、
前回がめっちゃ落ちて192だったんですけどもー
えっと今回が224と。
2年前と戻ってしまいました
コレステロールも、えぇとガツンとちょっと…
下がったけど、2年前に戻っちゃった感じです
中性脂肪も…
あれ、中性脂肪がちょっといい感じか？
うん。
中性脂肪は まあまあまあって感じですねー
はい、ここなんですよ。
ここがちょっと
今回の問題点だったかなってとこっスねー
コレステロールが、えー、上がってしまいました
これ去年の結果めちゃくちゃ良かったんですけども
これなぜかというとぉ、あの、
ラーメンを禁止していったからなんですよね
ラーメン禁止がマジで体に良かったみたいです
今年になってラーメン復帰して
今は食べてないんですけどもー
結局、お肉とか食べちゃうとぉ
やっぱ上がっちゃうみたいで。あとお菓子とかかな
まぁいろんな原因があると思うんですけども
総合的に見ると
ラーメンを禁止していた頃よりもやっぱ
コレステロール値が高い。デブに近づいた。
ということが明らかになりました
お医者さんも言っていたんですけども
ラーメンはとても危険な食べ物らしいです
もうご褒美に
たまに1回食うぐらいならいいんですけども
それを毎日のように食べ ていると
間違いなく太って、しまう。
これを含めて私はじめしゃちょー
ラーメンを食べるペースを
ちょっと見直そうかなと思っております
現在ラーメンを禁止しているんですけども
また夏休み明けた頃から
ラーメン食べると思うんですけども
そんなに食べ過ぎずに。
まあご褒美程度に、たまに食べるぐらいで
いいかなと思っております
以降ラーメン食べるとき気をつけようと思います
あと野菜しっかり食べます
続いて糖代謝も問題なかったです
ありがとうございます
あと肝機能とかなんか色々あるんですけどもー
血液も問題なかった、です
白血球、血小板。
何も問題なかったです
心電図も問題なしぃ
胸部も問題なしぃ
バリウム飲んでも問題なし！
肺機能も問題なし！
というわけでぇ、あのぉ…
これ僕ホント驚いたんスけどぉ
ラーメン…やばいなって思いました
ラーメン食べてない時と食べた時に、こんなにぃ！
中性脂肪とかに差が出るのかってぐらい。
ま、ラーメンが全てとは言わないです、でも、
大きな原因はそこなのかなと思いました
見て。だって、中性脂肪とコレステロール値。
去年が良すぎてビビるもん、マジで。
2年前と今年がもう…高いんですけど
去年がすっげー結果が良くて。
や、なんかねぇ、改めて…
僕、運動はちゃんとしてるんでぇ！
あとは食生活とか、お菓子とかかな。
あと野菜をしっかり食べ なきゃなって、思いました
まあ、なんせ、なんかやばい病気とかが
見つからなくて本当によかったです
結構めちゃくちゃな生活してるんだよね
な、なんかね！ほんと怖いんスよ！
どっかで引っ掛かったり、やばい何かを こう…
爆弾抱えてそうで心配だったんですけどもー
あの、毎年ちゃんとこうやって検査することによって
早期発見もできるし
ま、なんかやばいことがあったら
早めに…こう… 決心がつくというか。
何にせよ
あの、早期発見が一番大事なので
人間ドッグ受けててよかったなと思います
大変なんだけどね！
バリウム飲むのとかまじできついかんね。
はい、というわけで、毎年ですね、
最後に生涯目標を書かされるんですよ
あの、生涯の目標をどうしますかっていうの。
えーー、今年、の、生涯目標は
こちらです！
海ぞく王にオレはなる！
[通常ED]